if you think the last dance is a
complete slam dunk here are
five other titles totally worth checking
out on this week's binge guide
the 10-part donkey series following the
1997-1998 chicago bulls championship
team that espn so graciously released
early for us is certified fresh and fans
are loving the behind the scenes access
to this championship team
and arguably one of the most famous
sports figures in history michael jordan
so if you're loving last dance
here's what we think you guys should
watch next starting with our certified
fresh pick
hoop dreams this film from 1994 is one
of the most critically acclaimed
documentaries
of all time it follows two young men
from inner city chicago during their
entire high school career
from the playground to college
recruitment and all the obstacles in
between
critics call it a rich complex
heartbreaking and ultimately deeply
rewarding film that is much more than
just basketball
and it was shot over the course of five
years the last dance may show hoops at
the highest level but this 171 minute
film proves that the sport can be an
intense journey at any age
next up is our throwback pick and that
goes to 1998's certified fresh high game
which hit theaters not long before
michael jordan's final shot drop for the
chicago bulls
starring denzel washington and a young
nba star at the time now hall of famer
ray allen
this film is about a prison inmate
trying to get an early release by
talking his estranged son into playing
basketball for the governor of new
york's alma mater
written and directed by spike lee the
critics say that he got game
includes his signature visual styles and
finds him at or
near the top of his late period game
this was his 12th joint
at a little over two hours this film is
an entertaining watch and includes
cameos from a couple of last dance
centerpieces scotty pippen
and michael jordan and coming in with
our under the radar pick is the 2017
documentary icarus
this certified fresh film with a strong
audience score is about a major olympic
cheating scandal that is
uncovered by accident when director
brian fogle and russian scientists
realize that their combined knowledge
points fingers at russia's secret sports
doping program critics call this one
eye-opening viewing for professional
sports enthusiasts but also
gripping for film goers who might not be
drawn to the subject
this oscar winner for best documentary
clocks in at just under two hours and is
intriguing like the last dance but for
totally different reasons
and this week's rotten pick we love goes
to the 1997 action flick
double team this one stars the one and
only dennis rodman bringing his wild and
crazy persona that you've seen on last
dance to the big screen
and he's joined by popular action stars
at the time like jean-claude van damme
and mickey rourke in this story of an
international spy who rescues his family
from a terrorist by teaming up with an
arms dealer played by dennis rodman
and while it's not centered around
basketball rodman's character has
plenty of gadgets and cheesy one-liners
to bring you right back to where he
comes from
and during the 90-minute run time keep
an ear out for the crystal waters r
b song just a free that also features
dennis rodman
and finally for our editor's pick this
week we're going with the espn docu
series 30 for 30.
this long-running show features an array
of different filmmakers documenting a
variety of sports stories from
every angle last dance fans will
appreciate topics like the celtics
lakers rivalry the detroit pistons bad
boys teams who are also featured in last
dance
michael jordan's briefston in baseball
remember that
and the trial of alan iverson the fab
five and so much more
binging all this is a tall task but fans
can pick and choose from the 98
different episodes plus the 30 for 30
shorts to find topics that they're most
interested in so you'll have plenty to
binge if you start there
all right friends hopefully this will
help guide you through your next few
bench sessions i'm gonna go binge space
jam on netflix but be sure to check back
for more recommendations and ideas based
around the shows you love
right here on the rotten tomatoes binge
guide bye